he went from playing a president on TV
to being one in real life this is the
moment vladimir's olenski the new
president-elect of Ukraine found out
that he'd won on the world stage he's
just the latest political novice with an
affection for social media to sweep
aside the old guard thank you everybody
Solinsky actually studied law at
university but never practiced instead
opting for a burgeoning comedy career in
2015 he began starring as a fictional
ukrainian president in the sitcom
servant of the people his own political
party was eventually named after the TV
show Jillette Sookie has been the
unlikely frontrunner for most of the
election with poll ratings flying he
even went so far as to not show up for
one of two scheduled stadium debates
against incumbent Petro poroshenko the
fact that Ukrainians have already spent
years watching him play at being
President may have helped him ascend
zalenski projected a sense that people
could trust him whereas poroshenko the
more experienced candidate was seen as
corrupt next month I will leave my post
as president of the country this is what
was decided by the majority of
Ukrainians and I accept this decision I
will leave the office of the presidency
but I would like to emphasize I am NOT
leaving politics many Ukrainians are
looking for something new frustrated by
the slow pace of reforms and wearied by
the five-year conflict in the east of
the country
zalinsky they hope will usher in an era
of change
well joining us now from Kiev is our
correspondent Nick Conley Nick this is a
huge victory for Solinsky who has no
political experience has the
significance of this result sunk in yet
for the Ukrainians good morning Terry
well I think there's lots of scratching
of heads amongst the poroshenko camp at
least people really kind of taken aback
by the extent of that victory for valla
demos olenski yesterday him picking up
almost twice as many votes as the
incumbent so far we haven't heard any
more from him zalinsky yesterday
speaking only very briefly to the press
at his election campaign party first to
thank his team and then giving only the
briefest of indication of what he plans
to do as this transition begins saying
only that he would he would fire
Ukraine's current prosecutor general but
giving no further indication as to who
would be in his team but this is now
going to be a couple of weeks transition
before he finally gets into the
presidential administration a couple of
blocks behind me so you're saying that
his opponent is his opponent camp are
obviously scratching their heads but
what about the rest of Ukraine's
political establishment how are they
reacting well people seem to have
accepted this as a given with about 90
percent of votes now counted those exit
polls from yesterday evening have turned
out to be accurate we heard from the
prime minister volodymyr groysman
congratulating zalenski also beyond that
present poroshenko himself saying that
he would do his utmost to help zalenski
with contacts and help him in the
transition this was a very aggressive
campaign poroshenko throughout telling
Ukrainians that zalenski wasn't up to
the job so this was pretty impressive
and also magnanimous turn the speed with
which he accepted poroshenko accepted
his defeat and his willingness to accept
the results and not to question those
that did take observers by surprise but
that seems to be where he's going
poroshenko saying that he's lost the
battle but not the war that he intends
to stay in politics we have a
parliamentary election here in the
autumn Petro poroshenko saying he plans
to contest those and stay in Ukraine's
politics for now does anybody really
know what Solinsky is planning to do
here neck because in a debate last week
you said he wanted to break the system
nobody really knows what he means by
that and this at a time when Ukraine is
having to navigate very delicate really
a very delicate relationship in a
conflict with Russia well exactly Terry
and lots of his critics would say that
zalenski has tried to promise all things
to all people
he's more been about offering a sense of
generational change of being a new face
someone offering hope offering a more
positive campaign while being pretty
reticent on the detail of what he wants
to do in terms of the really big
questions in terms of joining NATO or
the EU zalenski says that he himself is
in favor but that he would put that
question to the Ukrainian people in
referendums in terms of Russia I think
it would be wrong to cast him here as a
straight forward pro-russian candidate
yes he is someone who speaks Russian
rather than Ukrainian in his personal
life he mixes the two languages in his
appearances but he's very keen not to
show himself as being Moscow's best
friend the Kremlin's best friend that's
something other candidates tried during
this election and it didn't do them any
good at the ballot box
there was one candidate who traveled to
Moscow before the first round and came
in fourth place so I think he has the
potential here as someone new to maybe
restart those talks about the future of
Donbass and to speak to the his Russian
counterparts without some of the baggage
that Petro poroshenko has picked up but
I think it would be premature to expect
Kiev and Moscow to make up in a hurry
and fazil ends key to make any quick
concessions to the Kremlin I think that
Ukrainian society would not accept that
given the war and these five years of
standoff we've had now that relieves us
something that is taboo in Ukraine's
politics nowadays Nick thank you so much
DW is Nick Connolly there in Kiev